If you ask a roboticist,
somebody who studies robots for a living,
what is a robot?
It's actually a very challenging question
to answer.
My name is Rebecca Kramer-Bottiglio, and I'm a
mechanical engineer and materials scientist.
When you conjure up an image of a robot,
you typically think of rigid machines
that perform repeated tasks,
and they don't adapt
to their environment because that's not
what they've been designed to do.
But when we think of robots for the future,
we imagine things like animals, like ourselves
We are incredibly adaptable.
We adapt our body configuration and our behavior
toward different tasks and environments
and we want to design
robots that can do the same.
And when we look at how animals adapt
to different tasks and environments, what we notice is that
all animals are at least partially soft.
There are no known animals in the world
that are completely rigid,
which is in contrast to the way
that we typically design robots.
And so I study soft robots, which are robots
made out of soft  materials.
Soft robotics is a broad field
touching on wearables,
and manipulation, shapeshifting
robots, and locomotion robots.
My group is developing novel, responsive
and intelligent materials
and embedding them into robots that can
perform novel behaviors like shape change.
And we draw upon inspiration from biology.
We have a turtle and tortoise inspired
robot platform with morphing limbs.
Turtles and tortoises
are morphologically very similar,
but they differ primarily in their limbs.
So when you think of sea turtles,
you think of elongated flippers
that are relatively flexible
and flat.
Tortoises have rounded limbs that are better for load
bearing and terrestrial locomotion.
So what we've developed is a morphing limb platform
that can switch back and forth between a flipper-like
morphology and a leg-like morphology.
And it allows the robot to accomplish
efficient locomotion both in water and on land.
What I love about working in robotics
is all of the intellectual challenges.
We have the opportunity to redefine
what is a robot from the ground up.